speaking of speaking of white people
thinking they're under attack I was
watching this over Bowl cuz every
American does and it was a crappy game
but the halftime show I thought was
pretty interesting and Beyonce yeah had
a great let's show a little bit of
Beyonce at the at the half
now to me watching that I was like well
this looks like every other halftime
show I've ever seen no wrong it was an
affront to everything we hold dear it's
a singing and dancing wild black and a
you know once again at the Super Bowl
black people misbehaving and what the
right wing was talking about rush
limbaugh said it was representative of
the cultural decay and social rot that
is befallen our country yeah same people
who think that's 40% unemployment um
hip-hop expert Rudy Giuliani it was
outrageous he said it was outrageous I
don't know what the heck it was a bunch
of people bouncing around and all
strange things what's wrong with a Perry
Como medley sung by up with people and
it's just amazing that the two Americas
they were because why because there was
some I first of all you can't even hear
the lyrics really no not really who's
listening well she did a video today
before she did that in the video oh the
video there's a little bit of the video
but this was not at the Super Bowl this
is from the video of the same song yeah
stop eating stop shooting us yes
absolutely yeah yeah well let me
speaking of white slide and white
fragility um white people it's not
always about you and pick it allowed me
but it is when you hear her talk about
the record she said you know like it's
first I'm not in the Illuminati she's
talking to other black people saying
look stupid because I'm not at Ferguson
when you want me to be doesn't mean I
sold you out and then the rest of the
first verse is about her telling other
black people I like being black this is
the type of black I am I like the fact
my daughter's black I like my own
Michael Jackson knows I like my child
with an afro I like me white people that
conversation wasn't even for you now
well good Mike what what scares gonna be
out what she what she sang was ladies
time it's called formation yeah ladies
time to get information which means kill
whites I think we all know
a message clear out of michiel husband I
tried to change it to my wife hit me Oh
what I want to say about the Black
Panthers other white people the history
they teach you in white school is not
exactly right the Black Panthers were
called the Black Panthers but they
weren't just pro black people there was
either an Asian black panther people it
wasn't Margaret the Black Panthers were
a socialist group for any downtrodden
people and at that time they happen to
be blacks but they said all people sure
I'm Fred Hampton was 21 years old and
when he talked he talked about educating
the people not just the black people so
white people we're ever great in the
Pampas Panthers - they don't have to be
afraid anymore well listen I was just
like you I think you know I had to be
broken down for days for me to
understand what the message was I think
I was so traumatized a puppy monkey baby
horrific gasps I just could not figure
out what my message was and I do and the
people who can't but I mean no
Vietnamese yeah there was even worse so
it was the most horrible word Horrocks
oh you know when I see beyond the one
performer doing her dance routine better
is the white guy in the panel I guess I
recognize the meal Oh miss is a white
political reporter bit for for Trump's
America been the only sober person
watching the image of dancing black
militants is like their nightmare come
to life and right right in the middle of
the the big game but every Republic is
what every dance number looks militant
like it didn't look like anything
different than I've seen but there
wasn't on to black power stuff and
they're all ginned up because a Trotter
is a good reporter you got in honor that
our black pride doesn't have to take
anything away from white culture it
doesn't have to take anything away it
can exist on its own sure I think this
is what black America needed
it's what all of us needed it's really
important